say whatever you want you want to say
about me you don't want to say anything
about my bad my dad in front of me you
just don't want to say that it's not
good I was 25 years old we were at a
Christmas party with my dad nothing's
going right with my life but one of the
relatives made a sarcastic comment about
my dad my dad was divorced no girl went
from making money in Iran to all of a
sudden making 1,500 bucks a month at a
99 Cent Store he made fun of my dad and
I saw my dad's body move and change and
I looked at my dad and I looked at the
guy and I said um yeah we're leaving
we're not leaving I said that I'm
telling you we're leaving he says no I'm
telling you I said I'm you right we're
leaving we're walking to the Caron you
just embarrassed me in front of my
family I said no D I said they will
never ever talk to you like that ever
again they used to work for you now he
talks to you like that at this point I'm
a nobody I don't have a penny in my name
got $49,000 in debt said the world is
going to know your last name they're
going to have to kill me but they're
going to know who you are